es el único tribunal del mundo que puede
hacer eso porque las Cortes nacionales
no pueden Investigar un presidente hay
una inmunidad pero no hay inmunidad para
jefe de estado frente a la Corte
Internacional el tema ahora es como se
va a resta una Corte Penal Internacional
no tiene una policía global por eso el
arresto depende los estados nacionales
el presidente Putin no puede viajar a
Europa no puede viajar a Colombia no
puede dejar América Latina porque
Debería ser arrestado Entonces el tema
es que va a pasar Yo creo que un buen
ejemplo es lo que pasó con el presidente
de Sudán
intentaba Mostrar que él era inmune que
él viajaba coachinas tuvo escapar de
Sudáfrica porque Sudáfrica los jueces
ordenaron su captura pero básicamente la
comunión internacional
hizo un acuerdo con bachir donde bachill
hizo concesiones que permitió la
independencia del sur de Sudán
Y entonces por un tiempo no fue
arrestado pero dicen años
un debilitado presidente de bachill
sufrió un golpe de estado y está preso
Hoy está preso y están discutiendo con
la Corte Penal Internacional si lo manda
o no Entonces me parece que un fallo de
esta Corte Penal Internacional tiene un
impacto Más allá de que mañana el primer
punto muy inteligente tiene que evaluar
ahora cómo maneja este tema Cómo llega
una negociación porque sí él puede
lograr que lo protejan el consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas si hay un
acuerdo político que termine con la
guerra que termine con los problemas
puede protegerlo al presidente Putin y
suspender suspender la acción Así que
esta decisión de la corte si bien es
personal sobre Putin puede transformar
la forma en que estamos manejando el
conflicto no más guerra justicia y
discusiones sobre cómo en términos de